two close friends invite the wife of one
of their cousins on a trip to the beach
they plan to sleep with her however the
journey will reveal more important
things about life and some secrets that
can end their friendship will be
discovered on the way so today on cinema
recapped i'll show you and your mother
too
the film begins with tanach and his
girlfriend in bed since the next day
she'll be going on a trip
they both promise each other they will
not be unfaithful when they're apart the
girl's mother allows the notch to stay
over quite the opposite for his friend
julio whose girlfriend will also go on
the same trip but he has to say goodbye
in the morning while her parents are
home however they managed to sneak out
for a minute to bust a quickie before
saying goodbye then we see the two
friends taking their girlfriends to the
airport
and although they tell them that they
will miss them a lot behind their backs
they say they want them gone already on
the way to tanach's house they discuss
their future and the protests happening
in the city tanakh says he wants to be a
writer and that people have a right to
protest
while julio wants to study something
that makes him a lot of money and says
that just as people have the right to
protest he has the right to tell them to
shut up for causing so much traffic
while they're at tonight's house we see
the friends drinking and talking about a
future party with a third friend who
starts smoking but tanach does not want
them to smoke inside the house so they
go out to the terrace there tenach's
mother who is involved in energy cults
auras and esoteric practices thinks that
they are sad about their girlfriends and
tells them to remember that even in the
distance they are still connected to
them while at the party they were
talking about beforehand neither tenoch
or julio managed to seduce any girls
the following week they go to a pool of
a club to which they have access on a
day that is close to the rest of the
public
due to tenoch's father's influence they
start to race in which julio gains the
upper hand but to no chance of winning
by a long shot
and we see them having a good time and
talking about
their little friends in the shower since
they have a lot of confidence in each
other we see them at a wedding where to
notch is fed up with having to act so
courteously while julio although he
looks relaxed he does not quite fit in
with the audience of rich families they
both talk with hano a cousin of tenach
who is also a writer and with his wife a
spanish woman who has no family other
than her husband the two friends invite
her to a beach called la voca del cielo
while flirting with her until she
reminds them that she is married later
we see this woman named luisa
at a lab collecting some results for an
analysis while doing a magazine quiz
which reveals that she is a woman
fearful of claiming her freedom although
she does not agree with that while the
two friends touch themselves next to
each other we see louisa unable to sleep
in her room then she receives a call
from hannah who was drunk and tells her
that he cheated on her luisa hangs up on
him and starts crying the next morning
tanach receives a call from luisa who
asked if the invitation to go to the
beach still stands
the beach had been invented by the two
friends but even so they do not back
down and they take louisa to this
non-existent beach since cenote's father
had punished him from using his car
after having crashed it and not wanting
to study they decided to leave in
julio's car which he shared with his
sister so they had to negotiate for it
also they asked the third friend to help
them find a beach where they can be
alone with julia
the friend gives them some confusing
indications but since they have no other
choice they trust him then they pick a
julia from her apartment julio plays a
joke onto note at the gas station and
julia tells him that she is a dentist
although she never practiced because she
married hanno meanwhile julio and tenoch
tell her that they do not call each
other friends
but charolastras which is almost the
same as friends but the charolais does
have a manifesto of various rules and
statements
it is prohibited sleeping with the
girlfriend of another charlastra and the
truth is cool but unreachable along with
some other along the way a voiceover
which is present throughout the entire
film tells us details of tenoch and
julio's relationship regarding their
social classes such as julio lighting
matches in the bathroom of tenoch's
house and not leaving a bad smell
ortonoch lifts the lid of the bathroom
in julio's house with one foot so he
doesn't have to touch it at night they
go to dinner at an end where julia
confesses that her husband has been
unfaithful many times throughout their
marriage
while they say that they are faithful to
their girlfriends they do not believe
that they're cheating on them now that
they're traveling abroad
later they stay at a motel
she in one room and the two friends in
another the charlastra try to spy on her
from the window but only find her crying
so they leave instantly they resumed the
trip to the beach the next day talking
about ex-partners and sexual experiences
along the way
while we see many landscapes and
emblematic images of mexico such as the
quinceanera some crosses on the side of
the road police officers stopping people
for no reason
cows blocking the road and policemen
stopping humble artisans then their car
breaks down and they are dragged by a
tractor to a nearby town
the tractor driver does not accept any
payment for the favor and also gives
william his hat
they tore a little in this town and lusa
calls honor and leaves him a goodbye
message
later in the motel tenoch finds luisa
crying and she seduces him they do it
although tenoch doesn't last long
and julio can see them from the door
in some unexplainable way julio feels
betrayed like when he was a child and
saw his mother in the arms of his
godfather tenoch arrives very happy and
challenges him to race in the hotel's
pool
during which he lets him win julio gets
angry and said that he doesn't have to
let him win in addition he confesses
that he had sex with his girlfriend
which leaves tenoch with the same
feeling of betrayal that julio had
at night although they do not tell luisa
about this infidelity she detects
tension between the charlastras and
believes that it's her fault so at night
she refuses to sleep with tenoch then
tenotrix blows against julio who
apologizes for what he did with his
girlfriend
still tonight spends the entire night
demanding details of how the infidelity
happened while hudio tells him
everything in a way that seems less
painful
the next day they continue their journey
in silence luisa sees some people by the
road carrying a corpse and wonders how
long people will miss her when she dies
but she stops thinking about it because
she does not want to fill her head with
thoughts of death then as she believes
she was to blame for the division
between the charolastras she goes to the
back seat of the car to do it with julio
as well so she can keep things perfectly
balanced as they should be but tenoch
gets very angry and ends up confessing
to julia that he also slept with his
girlfriend julio stops the car in the
middle of the road and wants to fight to
notch who locks himself in the car lucy
tries to calm julio down but he throws
her aside and she gets angry taking her
suitcases and going to walk alone down
the road when they see her doing that
tenoch agrees to apologize to julio on
his knees and get luisa back
although they both agree that they will
only finish the trip to the beach after
they will no longer be friends
lisa also agrees to return with them on
the trip
although she puts various conditions on
them so that they no longer fight
while we see more mexican images like
people being detained by the police and
women washing clothes in the river let's
remember that the beach they were going
to probably didn't even exist
julio then takes a turn on the road
without knowing exactly where it led
and he gets stuck he decides to simply
turn off the engine and go to sleep they
thought luisa was asleep in the back
seat but what they didn't know is she
was too afraid to sleep but this fear
had nothing to do with them or the
unknown place they were in the next day
they discovered that they had actually
reached a beach so they set up camp and
then a family of fishermen arrive who
offered them to take them to a quieter
beach so they could swim on the beach
luisa has a great time with the children
although she does not answer anything
when the lady tells her that she would
be a good mother
meanwhile the charolastras seem to
regain their friendship as they play a
friendly game of soccer when they return
to their camp they find it full of pigs
so they decide to spend the night in the
room offered by the fishermen
then while the characters play soccer
luisa makes another call to hano in
which she says goodbye to him and tells
him that she did not leave home because
of his infidelities but for another
reason that he will later find out
she also tells him that
he was the love of her life and that she
does not hold any grudge and expects him
to do the same
at night the charolais and luisa start
drinking and laughs while luisa says
that mexico is a wonderful country where
life is breathed everywhere
then the friends start making fun of
everything
even tenoch's corrupted father
later they confess that each one has
slept with the other's girlfriend
several times
but they confess it while laughing
saying that it makes the milk brothers
later julio confesses to tenoch that he
has not only slept with his girlfriend
but also with his mother when doing a
spiritual cleansing for him
to notch get serious at first but they
end up laughing still at the same time
lisa puts a song on the jukebox and
starts dancing the three of them are so
drunk they start dancing together
and when they go to the room they have a
threesome and we even see that tenoch
and julio kiss
the next morning luisa talks happy with
the fishermen who invite her to visit
the surrounding bays while julio into
notch after waking up and realizing what
they did the night before they start to
vomit and they say they have to go home
as lisa wants to stay and get to know
the surroundings better she decides not
to go back with the charolastras
during their farewell luisa tells him
that life is like foam and that is why
they have to live like the sea upon
returning from their trip which was very
quiet fulio and tenochti distant
themselves
then their girlfriends broke up with
them when they returned from their trip
abroad
a year later
they meet again by chance on the street
and although they're uncomfortable they
decide to have coffee together julio
tells to nudge everything that has
happened with his other friends tenocht
says that he will study economics and
not something related to writing as he
had planned
and also tells him that luisa died of
cancer shortly after what had happened
on the beach
and he already knew that she was going
to die when she agreed to go on the trip
with them since tenoch had a date with
his girlfriend he has to say goodbye to
julio
julio insists on paying the bill
they will never see each other again
the end if you liked the video please
leave a like and subscribe to continue
receiving recaps of the best mexican
drama movies my name is tc and i'll see
you in the next video goodbye